i like that yeah you should yeah that's
your next book
let's see first there's there's dante
abandon hope all ye who enter
that be one the second would be
call me ishmael and the third would be
art is fraught with danger zach
it's good to remember you know all of us
who are writers or
actors or filmmakers or whatever we
should write that and put it
you know in our room to remind us art is
fraught
with danger it'd be good good thing to
remember
is that a personal mission statement no
i just said it and
i said it and i thought oh that's fun
should a writer have their own personal
mission statement
um you mean if we asked writers if they
had a mission statement would they have
one
maybe it's not even in full if
fully fleshed out there's just something
in them they know their own
abilities yeah they probably do i don't
have to make one up because i
i know what socrates said and that to me
is good enough
he said know thyself.
and then he said the unexamined life
is not worth living so those are two
pretty good mission statements wouldn't
you say
the unexamined life is not worth living
and
know thyself know thyself
do people still live an unexamined life
in this day and age
well we all to some extent i mean if i
examined my life totally i'd be
writhing on the floor in agony
but you know i think you can uh
you know i've i've been in therapy i
think a lot of people have had therapy
or they've read books on spirituality or
uh whatever you know gone on
retreats and meditations and whatnot and
i'm sure people have
examined their life to some extent of
course
i think you said though that good art is
not about
um and forgive me uh it was it was
something you said
about good art is not about you know
kind of like getting all your issues out
it's also about making the viewer
feel something and forgive me i'm no
it's
that's true you you know you're building
a chair so people can sit in it
i mean i can be as creative as i want
about making a chair
uh i know my wife got a chair the other
day that she really liked and
and we sat in it you know she looked
great she loved the way it looked and
she said i'm gonna put that in my office
and blah blah blah
and one day i sat and i went boy this
chair is really uncomfortable
so the artist
on some level they're making something
that they hope will touch or astound or
shock
uh the the viewer
i mean on one level you're doing it for
yourself you're
you're exploring your own uh
technical materials if you're a painter
if you're a writer you're a sculptor
a good friend of mine who's a
poet in a sculptures um
she began experimenting with cardboard
and made the most amazing things but
a lot of times she's just exploring
the materials what if i do this with the
cardboard and i bend it this way and i
glue it this way you you're
experimenting
with the material same with the writer
and other times perhaps you do care
about what the viewer will
think or get from it if you write a
story or a poem
or something you're you're saying
okay uh what i wrote you know i'm
it came out of me but it could be
clearer
i'm i don't think my reader's gonna get
it a hundred percent
so what do i need to add or cut
to make it work better because a piece
of writing
works it's a piece of writing it's like
a machine
it works you know you get a machine from
the hardware store and you plug it in
and it doesn't work you take it back
it might look good all the parts are put
together right way but something's wrong
it's not working and that you bring they
go oh
there's a washer here that needs to be
put here ah
well same thing with a piece of writing
or a poem i'll go
oh that image there is not clear if the
image is not clear
then there's no payoff at the end but
so i've got to make that image clear and
then the reader will get it when i get
to the end
so you're you're trying to figure out
whether it's a novel or a story or a
poem
or play or screenplay whatever um is it
working
here in this spot so when you edit
you're not always just correcting
grammar and punctuation
you're you're thinking of it as a device
that has to
do something to the viewer or the reader
so hmm something's not working here
what is it what do i have to do do i
have to cut something
add something maybe move this over here
oh sometimes when someone reads a poem
in my class
i will say to them read it backwards not
word for word but
line for line and it works better
backwards
because when we write we either
i mean it can work either way we go from
an idea to something specific or we
start with some
something specific and as we develop the
poem
we come into possession of a
big idea and sometimes it works better
when you go from the
idea to the specific and sometimes it
works better when you go from the
specific
to an idea so someone will read
something to me and i'll go oh okay they
they started with an idea and then they
got specific
if they flip it then the reader will get
the
specific first and then as the poet
comes into possession of the idea
it will make more sense well
that's a kind of uh simplified version
of that but
when you're writing you you you're
thinking
does this work it's a it's a machine
it's a it's a it's a it's an object you
know you put a quarter in and it should
do it what it's supposed to do and when
it doesn't
you fiddle with it you think of how do i
make this
work better and um
you know there's an old saying writing
is rewriting
so first drafts are usually
that's all their first drafts
i've never written anything that didn't
go through more than one draft
i in other words i've never written
anything that was perfect
the first time out now you're supposed
to ask me why
well okay i was actually thinking about
you said the scene the ending scene of
saving private ryan was very emotional
to you yeah
so do you think that that scene
meant different things to different
people well you you can't
know how something is going to affect
someone
uh people can be affected by something a
hundred different ways
all you can do as an artist or a writer
is to
make a good guess and say in order for
this scene to work
the line has to be different or i need
to put the line over here
or i need to cut the line and say it
this way
you can only guess you can only imagine
you know
and and ultimately you are satisfying
yourself you're saying
this works for me so hopefully it'll
work for others
now with the first draft you'd said
something previously i said that i've
never written
uh a perfect first draft
well there was also something you said
in another and you were supposed to say
okay but that's not what i'm actually
going to say though so what i'm going to
say
is is give you the answer if you don't
ask the question how about i ask the
question afterwards you can ask it any
time
let me ask a question about genius you
had talked about genius
i know what you're referring to oh you
do okay yeah what is it
i talk about the accidents of genius yes
thank you right
everyone has genius in them
they just don't know what it is what
they do know is their talent
and your talent will never produce
anything great
it will only produce something that's
good
your genius is what is capable
of creating something great but because
we rely on our talent
we often never get to our genius because
talent is the obstacle to genius
it's when you don't know what you're
doing sometime it's when you are falling
and you are you're just
at the mercy of the gods that your
genius
wakes up and says this looks like a job
for genius man
and genius comes through and you do
something
and it's amazing and what do you think
of the
two things someone says when whether
it's a painting or a story or a poem or
whatever
when they get something that's utterly
amazing
what do you think of the two things they
say to themselves
it's crap no they they know it's great
oh i see them what do you think they say
to themselves i'm a genius i'm amazing
no that's not what they say okay have
you ever had that experience where you
did something and you go oh [ __ ]
i thought just a minute ago yeah yeah
okay
what do you what do you say to yourself
i thought i was going to ask a brilliant
question and then i realized that it
wasn't
no you asked a different question sure i
wanted you to ask the question why
okay that's all i mean i've done things
where i thought it was amazing and it
and it didn't get that reception
and then vice versa but when you knew it
was amazing what was the first thing you
said
to yourself uh that it's powerful
yeah but okay i mean you know i'm
sorry my in my elementary world i'm
gonna say it i'm gonna say it and you're
gonna go oh of course you're right
okay you write something or you do
something as an actor maybe
in the middle of a scene and afterwards
you go oh my god
that was amazing and then you say to
yourself
where did that come from oh okay yes
because you don't know where it came
from correct all the other stuff you did
you know it came from your talent
you know that you know how to do that
stuff but this thing
you go where did that come from then
what's the next thing you ask yourself
how can i do that again exactly oh yeah
i gotta write how
how can i do that again right and the
point is
there is no formula for that
otherwise people would be accessing
their genius
constantly but they're not they're
they're usually depending on their
talent
which is uh understandable that's okay
but
talent will only get what's good
genius will get what's great but
your talent is your biggest obstacle
and when you let go of your talent
sometime and are willing to
fail because you have no idea what
you're doing
sometimes your genius comes to the
rescue
and when it does you do something
and it shocks you and your first thought
is
how did i do that and your second
thought is
how can i do it again because you want
to do it again
but you can't make it happen you can
only be receptive
to it happening you can only be
available
for it happening and how do you make
yourself available
and receptive by getting rid of your
talent
and if you think that's easy you have
another thought coming
because you and your talent are in
cahoots
you say to your talent make me look good
and i'll keep you on the payroll and
your talent says
keep me on the payroll and i'll make you
look good
so the two of you got a deal going here
you're both gonna make
the artist look good but that's not what
you want
what you want is something great
and it's always unexpected and it's
always an
accident of your genius and the accident
happens
when you're falling off a cliff and all
of a sudden you fly
you wouldn't fly if you were on on earth
you can't make it happen but you're
falling you're in the unknown
you don't know what to do and you've got
to do something
because the moment is presenting itself
and when it does
you write something or you do something
with your paintbrush or
something or sculpting you put this here
and you go
how did i do that how can i do it again
so that's the the relationship between
genius and talent and guess what
i went to a chinese restaurant one night
and i got a fortune cookie
cracked it open and you know what it
said i've kept it
all these years it said talent
does what it can genius
does what it must i like that and i want
that's it
talent does what it can it's limited it
does what it can
but genius does what it has to do
because you're in trouble
you're falling off a cliff you've come
to a point in your art where you have no
idea what to do next
and you blunder into something and you
go
[ __ ] where'd that come from
how do i do that again and is that where
people get themselves in trouble
is they think that they can duplicate
that over and over again
well i don't know what you know gets
themselves in trouble i mean
look yeah the whole idea of
creating art is to get yourself in
trouble as much as you can
but and in acting too my acting teacher
always used to say
put yourself in danger he said that not
not
not get yourself in trouble he said put
yourself in danger what he meant was
be in a place where your character is in
danger and
things will happen um you know
none of us want to be in trouble we do
the best we can
and we will rely on our talent the more
talented you are
the more you will rely on your talent
the less talented you are
the more likely you are to have creative
accidents because you have nothing to
rely on you have no idea what the hell
you're doing
and sometimes you know the amateur
you know wins at poker the first night
because they you don't know what you're
doing
so that can happen but if you're going
to do it long enough at some point you
can't say i'm an amateur anymore you
have to say look
i know what i'm doing i have some talent
i know i'm going to rely on it sometime
but if i can once in a while get rid of
my talent
my hopefully my hopefully
because if your genius came up every
time you got rid of your talent then it
would be simple
it's the accidents of your genius and
when it doesn't come up what happens
you you create [ __ ] i'm a failure uh
not i'm a failure i've this
failed right now and that's how i get
better
by failing my attitude toward failure is
this doesn't define who i am just
because i drop the ball when i'm
juggling doesn't mean
i'm not a good juggle i can i can be a
good juggler i just have to keep doing
it
so how i interpret the failure is
different from the willingness
to have that happen when you take a risk
and most of the time when you take a
risk
genius doesn't come see that's that's
the point
it's an accident of your genius it
doesn't always come but are you
willing to lose a few times
to get something great because when they
give you the nobel prize karen
they are not going to take it away
because someone went back to your home
and rooted through your trash can
and found that you wrote 100 poems that
were [ __ ]
they're not going to take it away that's
what every artist does they write
they write crap they fail it happens all
the time
they're willing to take chances so no
one's going to take it away from you
when you win the nobel prize
but you got to be willing to fail and
when you do
it may not end up being great but you
got to keep at it
because when you're willing to face that
unknown when you put yourself in danger
not knowing where you're going and you
risk failure
sometimes sometimes
the accident of your genius comes up
it's like a mushroom-shaped cloud
you